7 of 9 from the field some of its great  offense and some of it not so great  defense that's a good job exploiting how  draymond Green is defending not playing  heartless so looking at them  short-handed I'm looking at who's on the  floor and thinking we've got to win this  game  curry presses shoot back to curry  it'll take to get rid of Willard  deserves 25 points for Meyers Leonard  Harry Turner guarding curry the repto  sets the screen curry long distance way  outside but see steph curry comes off  that screen big guy sitting further back  you makes them pay the price curry for  three  that's good curry answers back on in  2016 1 in 2017 as curry nails a  three-pointer and it's a five-point game